-These films obviously
are known for their singing,
for the vocal chops
you guys all bring to it.
But you now are,
to some degree, an action star.
You had to do multiple stunts.
-Seth, I'm glad
you brought this up,
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Because, yeah,
Fat Amy mysteriously turns into
an action hero in this film.
-Uh-huh.
-And, luckily,
I do have a bit of a background
in martial arts and karate.
-All right.
-So if I need to,
I can just...
-How far into the karate world
did you get?
Pssh!
-Oh, yeah, you're very good.
-Like --
-I'm not an expert,
but I can tell,
you're very good.
-Like, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
-Can you do that one more time?
Because that's -- that's wow.
-Look at that reach.
-Yeah.
-I have both legs.
-If a ninja made the mistake
of getting his head right there,
good night.
-Yeah. That's how
you get the little ninjas.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
It was so much fun.
Like, I did my own stunts.
And I fight off
a lot of bad guys in the film,
and the rest of the Bellas
get kidnapped.
And it was really cool.
While some of the other girls
were doing dancing stuff,
I was doing, like,
hard-core action training.
And, yeah,
I can really throw down.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I don't know.
If anything happens,
like, we're trying
to get out of the studio safely
or something...
-Oh, you could be the one
to take the lead.
-Yeah, I will take the lead
in the fighting.
You stand behind me,
and I'd just like --
Pch-chu-chu!
You know?
I also do my own sound effects.
[ Laughter ]
-Very helpful in a fight.
-Hyah!
Yeah. But I actually --
The scariest stunt I did.
I did a 20-foot free-fall jump
with my co-star, Anna Kendrick.
I know, it sounds mental.
Even when we finished the stunt,
the stunt team were like,
"Oh, uh, no actress we know
would actually do that."
[ Laughter ]
And we're like,
"Why didn't you tell us that?"
Because I know
I seem really tough,
but I am afraid of heights.
-Yeah.
-That's the one thing
I'm afraid of.
And I had to do
this 20-foot jump.
-Just once, hopefully.
-10 times.
-10 times!
-10 times with Anna Kendrick.
And each time, petrified,
thought I was gonna die.
And so, the lovely Anna Kendrick
sang to me.
So, each time
we were hoisted up,
she would sing random stuff
to distract me
and try to make me laugh.
Like, she was singing a lot
of Bette Midler classics.
[ Laughter ]
She was like
♪♪ Going to the chapel ♪♪
♪♪ And we're gonna get married ♪♪
I'd be like,
"Keep singing, keep singing."
Yeah.
So that was
a very special memory of mine.
-Well, that's fantastic.
And it's such
a special set of films.
Congratulations
on being part of it.
And we're very excited.
The soundtrack,
which is fantastic,
everyone here is gonna be
leaving with it tonight
as a Christmas gift.
-Oh, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Courtesy of Rebel.
Rebel Wilson!